what's happening in the brain and body
when we procrastinate oh um yeah so
procrastination is super interesting
there actually some data that Adam Grant
shared with me recently that people who
procrastinate actually have um tend to
be have access to certain creative
states that non-rr inators don't because
they have don't start justifying the
procrastination crowd that's a dangerous
line to go yeah procrastination I mean I
mean what the origins of procrastination
are are complicated and varied um to to
really say a single concise statement um
as to what procrastination is but the
way to overcome procrastination is to do
something harder than the hard thing
that you're putting off that's very
clear do something harder don't go clean
your like suddenly people want to do
their their taxes clean their room clean
the garage organize the gym whatever
when they don't want to write a chapter
in their book but you have to pick
something that's worse than writing the
chapter in your book and do that for
five minutes that's the way that the the
dopamine reward system works and some of
these stress systems work um what would
be an example give me give me a tactical
example of this okay I need to write a
chapter on focus and um and tools for
Focus for my book I'm finding I'm doing
everything but doing that let's just set
it kind of a fun example um I'll do
anything but that okay so then you have
to find something worse than that so for
me worse than that is anything involving
a spreadsheet just the idea of a
spreadsheet gives me hives so I would
force myself to do five to 10 minutes of
like like really like establishing a
spreadsheet of my expenses and taxes
related to I don't know some segment of
my work life I mean I can't think of
anything worse in that moment that
doesn't involve physical or
psychological damage so doing that and
then you'll see it will make writing
that book chapter very accessible it's a
down it's a downhill cruise from there
but people find themselves doing all
these things that they would normally
want to put off as a way to avoid doing
the harder things so it's it's it's
about understanding that what is
difficult and what you want to put off
or do is a dynamic hierarchy I think uh
you can think of it as Dynamic
subordination um you know I don't know
if that's bother borrowed from cosplay
or from uh military or BDSM I I don't
know I heard it some place um but all
the places that you mine for information
most frequently no it's raccoons and
street fights no none of those none of
those communities are communities that I
I know very much about but um I was
saying it factiously but um but the
point being do something harder than the
thing you're trying to avoid now some
people really like deliberate cold
exposure for that reason because you and
here I'm going to really if I've taken
heat for no pun intended for the
deliberate cold exposure thing now I'm
really going to get behind it for the
following reason people who are really
into exercise of various kinds but not
deliberate cold exposure love to push
back on people that do posts about
deliberate cold oh that's not doing
anything it's not much metabolic lift
okay but let's really step back and be
honest with ourselves the adrenaline the
the the the pattern of adrenaline
release over time from deliberate cold
exposure is something that's very hard
to recreate safely with other endeavors
you know sure a hard workout is going to
spike your adrenaline and dopamine also
but is it going to spike it the way that
deliberate cold exposure is no also the
amount of a of a mental barrier that one
has to get over in a moment not there's
no like three warm-up sets like walk on
the treadmill preout me the pre-cold
plun drink that makes it easier okay
it's
called willpower yeah okay and now some
people come to love deliberate cold
exposure but that's usually for how they
feel afterwards so I think there is so
much utility to deliberate cold exposure
now do people have to do it no but
deliberate cold shower deliberate ice
bath deliberate cold plunge is a is a
world apart from all the other
self-imposed stressors because of the
speed of onset of the stress it's even
even more so than a SAA
that's right you get into a saer and it
takes time for you to heat up it takes
time for you to get uncomfortable I mean
it so it's a very potent tool because of
the amplitude and the timing of
adrenaline that it creates in other news
this episode is brought to you by
marrick health I wanted to get my blood
work done here in America I'd been told
by people like Dr hubman that it's
important for me to do to work out
what's going on inside of my body but I
didn't know where to go after a ton of
research I found out that Mar health is
the best and most comprehensive when I
started working with them my
testosterone was $495 which is low
normal not where I wanted it to be now 6
months later it is 106 and I'm not on
trt that is what happens when you work
with a proper comprehensive blood panel
company who genuinely knows what they're
doing with Maric Health it's like having
someone in your corner that is a
properly trained clinician who knows
exactly what's happening inside of your
body and can give you personalized diet
supplementation training and
pharmaceutical recommendations plus
organize it all it is a One-Stop shop
for your health you can get the exact
same medical panel and oversight that I
got by going to the link in the
description below or heading to Marik
health.com wisdom and using the code
modern wisdom a checkout for 10% off
that's M AEK
health.com wisdom and modern wisdom a
checkout thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that clip with Dr
hberman you will love the 3our episode
that you can watch right here go
on press it